Fox host Neil CAVUTO has not been playing
up Donald Trump's promotion of hydroxy chloroquine.
He's not stopped short of going after Trump
for his absolutely ridiculous musings about
bleach injections.
And now, after Donald Trump has asserted that
he is taking prophylactic hydroxy chloroquine
to protect himself from Corona virus.
Neil CAVUTO is saying this will kill you if
you have certain co-morbidities.
Let's listen to the start of Neil CAVUTO segment
about this yesterday.
That was stunning.
The president, United States, just to acknowledge
that he is taking the drug, chloroquine, a
drug that meant really to treat malaria, lupus.
The president's insistence that has enormous
benefits for patients either trying to prevent
or already have covered 19.
The fact of the matter is, though, when the
president said, what have you got to lose
in a number of studies, those are certainly
vulnerable in the population wanting to lose
their lives.
Then kabuto going in even harder a little
bit later on in the segment saying this will
kill you in certain situations.
The V.A. study to which the president alluded
wasn't a loaded political one.
It was a test on patients there and those
who took it in a vulnerable population, including
those with respiratory or other conditions.
They died.
I want to stress again.
If you are in a risky population here and
you are taking this as a preventative treatment
to ward off the virus, or in a worst case
scenario, you are dealing with the virus and
you are in this vulnerable population.
It will kill you.
I cannot stress enough.
This will kill you.
So listen, Neil CAVUTO is horrible.
Neil CAVUTO has been spreading disinformation
on Fox News for decades.
This is not any kind of praise of Neil Cavuto's
journalistic skills or credentials in any
way.
But CAVUTO is right about this.
Maybe he knows Fox News has a disproportionately
older audience.
CAVUTO is saying the right thing and he's
now in hot water with the virulent Trump ists
who are calling for his firing.
Now, one thing that Trump said didn't look
so good was that one V.A. study that says
hydroxy chloroquine doesn't seem to work to
treat Corona virus.
It is a good thing that Neil CAVUTO pointed
out.
That's a good study.
In fact, we have a lot of different studies
on hydroxy chloroquine.
That's probably the best randomly controlled,
randomized controlled trial with a placebo
group.
And it was a blinded study.
So good, good that Neil CAVUTO is doing this.
Meanwhile, Sean HANNITY and Laura Ingraham
and others on Fox News have been gleefully
promoting this drug and it's completely dystopian.
We have Fox News hosts arguing with each other
over which drugs people should be taking rather
than leaving it to the doctors.
Here's Laura Ingraham bringing on a guest
last night who says we should be thrilled
that Donald Trump is taking this because he's
brilliant.
Check out this wacky woman, doctor.
If that Lozano doctor was on our people on
television news anchors, gas or freaking out
about this, what about this?
Should we, the American people know?
Is that irresponsible of him to be taking
hydroxyl chloroquine?
And why do they care?
I think the people of the United States need
to know that they have a brilliant president
of the United States and that he wants to
keep themselves safe and healthy so that he
can guide us through this pandemic.
He's done an incredible job.
He is saving thousands and thousands of lives.
And I commend him for coming out publicly
and sharing with his people that he is taking
this job, that it is completely safe and that
doctors need to start prescribing it immediately.
Of course, it's not completely safe.
And just a reminder, I have no ideological
opposition to hydroxy chloroquine working.
They are promoting this as a miracle drug
and that is not based, in fact.
Last thing.
Is this entire hydroxy chloroquine thing from
yesterday a distraction from the number of
Corona virus deaths from Trump firing his
fourth inspector general in a few weeks?
We are still covering all of those stories,
but other media outlets are spending a lot
of time on this instead of some of those stories.
And it could be once again one of Trump's
planted distractions.
We'll have more cover of the coverage of this
on The David Pakman Show Instagram page at
David Pack in show.
Follow us there.
I'll be
right back.